let me context
the contextualize the what we're going
to do and what we've been doing uh
lately like you you guys are you're in
the middle to the bottom and the skill
development right and um you've been
dominating in terms of majority like
who's here what's the bul of the class
okay so we're really personalizing it
towards you you also have your knee
problems right and so
we're doing things you could do okay I
think first of all you guys should pay
attention to
that um and be aware of that for you A
lot of the stuff is intuitive like you
just grew up in it and you kind of just
and it's probably the best way of
training but it won't be the best way of
teaching okay and so what I'm giving
you is um the concepts behind why you do
things the way you do which you'll need
to teach people okay because most people
obviously they can't do just by watching
everything gets filtered and
changes and that's kind of what happened
and why it will be helpful to you to
return to the basics because when you
first got them you changed them ever so
slightly
um and in and done so in a way that they
make it difficult for you to get to the
higher levels Okay the reason for this
is is that concentric nature between
things right so you have a kind of uh
let's just call it character for the the
beginning here uh the ability to receive
something purely without any filtration
right is a kind of release of self do
you see that and ultimately where you're
headed is a release of self so when we
filter something at the beginning we're
not releasing self in some ways it's
going to be
antithetical uh to whatever you're doing
and then at a certain point it will be
antithetical to such a degree that you
now can't do this other thing okay so
we're going back and you're going to get
another chance at it okay so let's we're
going to work at test test iaki okay uh
a lot of times for example as you're
trying to ground let's just use that one
as you're trying to ground or root it
gets trapped in your shoulder and in
your bicep and while ultimately it
doesn't really matter what position your
arm is or what geometry your arm takes
it's very
difficult to get yourself in the
ballpark
with an arm geometry that is not
conducive towards getting in the
ballpark okay so we want to understand
how our arms move okay and why they move
that way all right how about we hand
that to and you could get your chair or
whatever so when I say you can do
whatever then you need to do whatever
okay my expectation is that you're not
going to beat yourself up in any way
emotionally mentally you're it's your
thing on
how left in or left out you feel
okay does that make sense
okay um and same thing you be
comfortable all
right
um
so in the
tabaki you know you have you have an
inward spiral and you you have your
outward spiral okay they kind of make
that heart shape and everything I do I
need to do
that my arms don't go up and down and
they don't go in and out okay I have my
inward
spiral and I have my outward
spiral even though I name it in and out
you you have to
understand that in those two movements
of the arm you will be able to be what
the inward spiral can work on its
outside as well as on its inside and
same thing goes for the outer spiral
okay like for example in the in the suto
kiten from last night you had an inward
spiral but you were on the outside of
the arm and and that was really freaking
you guys out okay but remember the
ultimate aim of the art is that DST aim
of Jang ding which is a Reconciliation
of dichotomy so it doesn't make sense
that you would have an art that
ultimately goes in and out okay in and
out has to be able to become out and in
but
also down and up up and down
okay
so I I have those two moves we're going
to look at we're just going to draw a
torso
here here's the
head
your outer line that is your outer rim
so if you remember your outer rim right
it's that area that comes down to the
bottom of the lower tanden is this kind
of oval shape
okay and remember your elbows always
stay within your outer rim elbows never
go outside the outer rim this is not
martially viable you're not protecting
your vital organs
okay on the
Torso this side of your shoulder
down is
y quarter of your chest I'm drawing a
vertical grid is
Yin the middle of your chest is that
equilibrium then you have another middle
of your chest so what do you think that
is y
Yin and then
another outer line is y
okay
my elbow is my marker not not my hand
okay my elbow is my
marker what I'm trying to do here by
never putting my elbow outside the outer
rim for example and by moving in the
inner and ouward spiraling motion as
opposed to moving my arm this way or
this way to achieve
things if is this deltoid muscle here
and all the tendons that go into its
functioning is a martial weak
point it just it just cannot do the
job so chibba Sensei didn't
do this notion he had all kinds of other
ways of moving this guy was very strong
he had injured shoulders okay you will
injure your shoulders eventually just
over Decades of practice practice if
you're not using this inward outward
spiral okay the inward outward spiral is
a way of
not utilizing or isolating the inner
deltoid or the upper deltoid and instead
bringing in back muscles to support that
joint on the Yang
side so the shoulder joint is going to
get in a way just metaphorically kind of
fused or
strengthen but on the inside which we do
all the time is I now once I know how to
fuse it I can know how to release it
okay and that releasing is something you
always do in your Yin yields so recently
we did tenaga remember and Bo there was
my Yin yield on that arm going this way
W I make contact with their head right
here do you remember
and I'm not going to go like this that's
going to hurt it I'm going to release
the shoulder release the shoulder okay
or in koku going this
way remember I bring their head to the
arm what does the reversal on the Y
yield boom freeing the shoulder freeing
the shoulder boom and then they go
backwards okay so I want to learn how to
fuse it for integrity reasons
but I also want to know how to release
it for U iy strategies
okay if my elbow goes outside here you
can do this looks like an inward spiral
do you see that but it's not
accomplishing what I want okay in terms
of that shoulder Integrity so we have to
pay attention to these lines okay and
we're going to work with three levels
again in a Triune cosmology there's that
three again we have
jodon
Chon and
gon Don means level upper level middle
level lower level
okay and I will transition between these
levels with either an inward spiral or
outward spiral or a combination of the
two which
means you don't do these differently
like Chiba Sensei did you just
extend or
inverse the Inward and outward spiral so
keep that in mind because I know some of
you do this Chiba Sensei thing what is
that because we're going to prioritize
the positioning of the elbow and the
structural Integrity of the
shoulder you don't want to
hinge at the elbow this should not this
should never happen Okay what I want to
do instead is the upper arm bone is
actually where all my extension is once
I set the shoulder in place as
described so right now if I
am using if I'm thinking I'm holding
them out and I'm maintaining positional
Integrity here this is where you start
to use the bicep and
tricep but if you set the
shoulder and you realize it's the upper
arm bone that's actually
doing that maintenance of that
positional Integrity such that's why we
do this drill he's pushing
it doesn't it doesn't change the feeling
I set this and the key thing here is
there's no hinge
here and so the bicep and the tricep do
not have to flex okay I keep this elbow
in place which happens by making my
upper arm
bone my
extension maintenance okay by keeping my
shoulder locked if I don't keep my
shoulder lock this is where you start to
see all this stuff do you see okay so
we're going to look for this I'm not
flexing my
elbow not bringing in tricep and bicep
into it my elbow never goes outside my
outer rim and I only make use of these
movements here for all the movements
okay but these movements here are going
to be understood in a Transcendence kind
of way so when I'm moving in inside I
could be using the outside okay when I'm
moving down I could actually be bringing
them up Etc and at some
point when you
go from gon to Chon to jodon you're
going to take one of those
Spirals and convert it from working on
the sagittal plane to working on the
vertical plane like we did yesterday in
uchai 10 okay we'll do that a lot so
here we
go and we'll just use Tenon okay or tyo
heno so you can see it's it's like a
magic trick now that now that you
understand what's going as I always show
you relax right relax and but if you pay
attention this part doesn't really move
I'm not going like this do you see that
so because as I mentioned it's the upper
arm bone that's actually giving me my
positional Integrity that you can wiggle
the other stuff around see that
okay so we're here and we'll do gon and
gon is going to be part of your outward
spiral so you can see it it's your
outward spiral is in h you
ho so gon goes this way
we should see that angle of cancellation
in his elbow and already the beginning
of tilt in his body but
because I rotate you'll see that you
will it'll be hard to recognize the
outward spiral because I'm not going to
stay here if I stay here you would
eventually see the shape but because I'm
going to
rotate people think that my arm was
going
in
you see that and that's going to use my
inner d
s my arm is actually going
out my elbow if you pay attention is
starting on the Y Line on that
grid
hitting the yin line the contact point
is now on that Jang ding line that that
dynamic equilibrium or that Center
equilibrium okay and that is where the
turn happens one turn on that so when my
hand gets to that spot I should be
turning in other words here I go Yin
here's a dynamic equilibrium I went too
far and now I entered and turned you see
that I don't know if you caught that
do it this
way y y pass Dynamic pass the spine and
you get this closed off area you see and
now you enter and it's all
constricted so when do you rotate when
your hand hits that middle of
Yin
elbow
in all right let's
try let's go back a step because
uh in order to make my upper arm work
the way that I
described you have to not put your lower
arm in a place where you're going to
want to use your body bicep okay so
there is a a
natural degree of articulation in the
elbow that achieves that and the way to
find it is to lean over and let your
arms hang naturally with no tension and
that bend is what comes back making this
incorrect you see that if I'm hanging
over and I went like that you'd go relax
relax I am no you're not okay just let
your hands hang
hyperextending them again that would not
be relaxing so you find your natural
Bend then you bring that up and you keep
that okay let's try it again
go all right just going back a little
bit so you can understand how martially
precarious this joint
is okay he's going to try to bring me in
utilizing that inner deltoid
um now I'll give him some back muscle by
anchoring his elbow a little bit but
there's still a lot of inner and upper
deltoid here you go it's a little
stronger but you can still feel it right
okay and this is actually how a lot of
people get injured as I've mentioned
earlier okay you're you're using these
muscle roots all right what he's going
to do instead if you pay attention now
with our grid this elbow is way outside
that Y Line and that's what makes it
precarious it's also way outside the
outer rim which makes it not Marshal
what he's going to do instead is by
turning his qua he now brings the elbow
back on the Y
Line okay and what he's going to do
instead instead of doing this
part he's going to do the inward spiral
okay so he'd go
here so he brings that and when he turns
his hand he brings his quaw into it and
he's way way stronger okay that's what
we're trying to
do all right here we
go so as you as and I I hope you can see
that now what he's what he's hitting is
that upper armb
that's why this is all relaxed like this
okay so again y it's going to go to Yin
the hand going to go to the spine and
that's where the turn happens this is
where the Turning
happens don't let your elbows go back
out elbows are on that young line my
hands are outside it which is
fine
[Music]
again
and again it
is the hour spiral being used to appear
to go in okay try okay so we'll go back
a little bit he's going to bend over and
learn his natural arm angle he's going
to get a kinesthetic feeling of what
that is he comes up and he keeps it okay
what this armed angle does at the elbow
is it actually sets the upper arm at a
particular angle and that particular
angle is what allows the shoulder
mechanism to set in place as we want it
to be okay if he bends his arm you can
see that it changed the angle of the
upper arm and of course then it changes
the angle of the shoulder mechanism now
putting it in a less setable
position if we come back out to his
natural angle you can see that upper arm
changed its angle and therefore we're
now in the setable position for the
shoulder if we go the other way and he
extends that again the upper arm changed
its angle the shoulder changed its
setability as well okay so as he's doing
tenon for example just on your own like
you're doing it you go
a lot of times even on here slightly he
came in do you see slightly this arm
bent more that's not the natural angle
that he had before that's going to
change this angle this shoulder is now
not setable so from here he has to do
something else okay so as he does his
ten
con you you have a sense of what that is
because that sense is giving you this
which is making this
setable and he goes
and he needs to keep that cannot change
this angle like usually you go I want to
get heavy well you change that Angle now
and this is not setable okay so pay
attention to that
continue so to do Cheon you have to
first pass through gon pass through gon
this hand is again in that ding area on
my body and that's when I make the
transition over to
Chon starts with gon
turns when you turn into that hand
position don't go back and have this
hyperextended
elbow and then just spin your
wrist it's a spiral remember an inward
outward spiral so my wrist and elbow
cannot be on the same sphere turning at
the same time the wrist is going to
turn and then the elbow
follows because I went from gon to Chon
you'll see him lift a
little again my mind is on that upper
arm setting the shoulder so even though
I'm here and I'm moving my hands I'm
concentrating on the upper arm
[Music]
part when does the transition happen
again on that jine
line not before not after
all right let's go Che on you have in
the uh in the
historical energetic understanding of
the body you don't have seven
chakra
[Music]
um you have five five is always the
number so you have a a lower one a
middle one and an upper one that we want
to pay attention to here okay so when
you you get
on this is going to come to that lower
one your hot area and when you do Cheon
it's around your heart area Okay do
you're here like this not up here in the
shoulder area okay here like
this boom I pass through that lower
boom boom here in this heart area here
okay that's where chew on is end all
right try it again so as I noted earlier
and then just now where I was at the
lower and then I came to the
middle he should you should see an
elevation change in him okay so when I
go down you can see that he's going down
and when I came up from going down then
you should see that he's coming up okay
he he should not be walking around me
like that you should see an elevation
change and that's us con
verting these spirals that are working
on the sagittal plane well vertical I'm
going from vertical to sagittal and then
I'm going to go back to vertical and
that's jodon so I pass through gon my
rotation is when the grip reaches the
Jing on my body I pass through Chon and
then I'll bring that up cuz he was
already Rising that's where jodon
is it's not
then I go
here and flex my bicep and try to get
him
up he is being
lifted from the beginning and so he's
going up this makes this a Yin move I'm
following him I'm not lifting him he was
already being lifted
here
don't get greedy go here leave out Chon
and start to lift this it's not the same
chuon did the
lifting all right let's try it
Jon so what I was what I was trying to
say is that as you go into Chon I went
low and Chon is what moves him forward
and up and since he's going up there's a
Yin space and that's where jodon happens
jodon is not him down and then I lift
him up and he keeps his
grip I move him on Chon boom Chon boom
is going this way judon moves him up I
stay with his grip you see and now I
just move move myself into that
place get on CH do moves and pull look
how high my hand is and then I would
just move myself into that
place so resist here and then you
pulling his hand up like that you can
see there's way less action in his
Center so Bo boom that's what you want
okay then it is effortless you're not
using the bicep okay
go so just at the beginning I said this
is the hour spiral and gon but it
doesn't look like it because I changed
my orientation to it so it looks like it
was going in this
way jodon is your inward
spiral but I changed my orientation to
it and allowing me to convert it from
working on the sagittal plane to the
vertical plane again okay which is why I
don't just go here that's not one of my
movements a g I'm here in in Chon
passing through and then I Chang my
orientation to it if I didn't change my
orientation to
it you would see it's just this but I'm
going to change where I am now I'm going
to move myself over here and lower
myself and this is where you have your
Joon so resist the
temptation even as when it gets
effortless like you threw him so high
that yeah I'm just going to bend my
elbow okay instead finish the inward
spiral w
I'm going to keep that movement going
it's
just up
high so if you pay
attention where my hand ends
up is
not here like I'm doing the scuba diving
Universal signal for shark okay I keep
the spiral
going and the grab is on my Center Line
okay because I want that elbow closer to
my Center Line I I move this out like
this no that's not where that elbow
goes okay grab is on the Janine line
elbows on the yin line okay prior okay
we we ran into a common uh problem here
and uh it is part of of the tabaki
because we use the Tachi in the tenom
maneuver okay uh so the the problem the
goal that we want is that I don't start
entering and rotating until the grip
comes to that Center Line on me that
equilibrium between Yin and
Yong but if I bring the grip there and
don't move my body at all you get
crunched here and that's going to cause
problems so what our people here today
were doing is they go well I I'm feel
feeling crutched and so now they start
turning and now they turned without the
wrist on the center line maybe come over
here andw you see
okay
so there is in the way there is a
yangong and Yin grid on your chest
there's one on your quaw so I'm going to
bring the elbow into the Y Line it's a
little slower please let's here the
elbow is now on the Y line of the qua
and now the qua is what's going to
finish this and now I get
that the grip is on my Center Line okay
another thing to note
then is just like your inward spiral the
hand or the wrist spiral is doing
something different at a different time
to what the elbow is doing in its role
in the inward spiral the same thing here
here as you wouldn't turn them equally
it's not going to achieve what you want
I don't ever move my qua and my
elbow at the same way at the same rate
okay so you can see the elbows moving at
one rate to the Jing line same thing
here the qua will move there but at a
different
rate not at the same time that's going
to have you
pull so elbow comes to the qua Yong so
it already started and then the quaw
picks it up the hand is traveling at a
faster
rate push
now
okay